- [Instructor] Imagine
that I'm standing here
holding the end of a rope.
I'm over here on the left end,
and while holding the rope,
I rapidly moved my hand up, down,
and back to the starting position.
If we were to take a snapshot of the rope
immediately after I finished my motion,
we're going to see something like this.
The rope has a squiggly disturbance
that mirrors the motion
I made with my hand,
up, down, and back to the middle.
And the rest of the rope is still flat.
You might've seen something like this
if you've ever played with a jump rope
and wiggled it back and forth,
or a slinky and you've seen that oscillate
back and forth on the ground,
or if you've been in the gym
and seen somebody doing exercises
with large battle ropes,
slamming them up and down repeatedly.
And we know that over
time, this disturbance
is actually going to make
its way through the rope.
If this is what we observe
right after my hand motion,
at some later point in time,
we will observe that the
beginning of the rope
is back to its original shape,
the squiggly disturbance
has made its way further down the rope,
and it will keep traveling
in this direction
until it reaches the end of the rope.
This is exactly what a wave is in physics.
A wave is a disturbance, in this case,
the squiggle in the rope
caused by my hand motion,
and that disturbance can propagate,
it can travel or move in
a particular direction.
So a wave is a disturbance
that can propagate.
This particular example is
called a mechanical wave.
It's called a mechanical
wave because the disturbance
is traveling through a medium,
in this case, the rope.
So mechanical waves
travel through a medium.
One important point about waves
that is worth noting right now
is that waves transfer energy
without transferring matter.
So what that means
is that the disturbance
that is moving here,
this squiggly shape is
moving through the rope,
but it isn't moving the rope
to a different position.
Any part of the rope might go up and down
as the wave travels through that section,
but the rope itself is not going anywhere,
rather it's the kinetic energy
imparted to the rope by my hand
that is transferring
from particle to particle
and making its way through the rope.
So waves transfer energy, but not matter.
So in my first example,
I only jerked my hand up and down once,
which created a single wave pulse
that moved through my rope.
If instead, I were to keep moving my hand
up and down consistently,
I would see a wave form that
looks something like this.
And when we model a wave,
there are a few key characteristics
that we need to know
about that wave.
First is the period.
Period is measured in
seconds and it tells us
how long it takes for one
wave cycle to complete.
Next is the wavelength.
Measured in units of distance like meters,
the wavelength is the distance
between identical points
of adjacent waves.
And finally there's frequency.
So if the wave point that we've
drawn here takes one second,
there are four cycles in that one second,
that means it has a frequency of 4hz
or four cycles per second.
So the frequency measured
in cycles per second
tells us how many wave cycles
there are every second.
Now using just these basic
anatomical properties of a wave,
we can start to pick out
more interesting physical characteristics,
like speed or distance over time.
If we want to know how
fast a wave is traveling,
we can take its wavelength,
which is the distance
covered by a single cycle,
and multiply that by the frequency,
which is how many cycles
are completed in a second,
a given amount of time.
The cycles cancel out
and we're left with units
of distance over time,
the same as speed.
And that's our equation
for the speed of the wave.
Wavelength times frequency.
The standard units for
speed are meters per second.
There are a couple of factors
that can affect the speed of a wave.
The first is the wave type.
So different types of waves
move at different speeds.
A relatable example of different waves
moving at different speeds is lightning.
Have you ever seen lightning strike
or been in a thunderstorm?
You know that the first thing you see
is the flash of lightning,
and then you hear the thunder
associated with that lightning flash.
So the lightning comes first
and the thunder comes second.
That's because those
are two different waves
that are part of the same phenomenon.
When the lightning strike
hits, you see the flash first
because that's an
electromagnetic wave, light.
It travels much faster
than the sound associated
with the lightning strike.
Electromagnetic waves are special
not only because they travel really fast,
but they also don't need a
medium to travel through.
The thunder on the other
hand is a sound wave
traveling slower than the light.
So you'll see the lightning
before you hear the thunder.
Different wave types
move at different speeds.
The second key factor that
can affect the speed of a wave
is the medium through
which the wave travels
and we'll consider sound
as an example here.
So when someone is talking, right,
we have this talking head
creating some vibrations
of the particles in front of their mouth,
that's the sound wave.
It's the vibration of those particles
propagating through the air.
When you speak, your
vocal cords exert force
on the particles just in front of you.
They vibrate back and forth,
creating a compression
that transfers to the
surrounding particles.
As the vibrations continue to
propagate, the sound travels.
You can imagine
that if these particles
are packed closer together,
those vibrations are going to
transfer a lot more quickly
because the particles
are colliding much faster
than if they're further apart.
So sound travels much
faster in water, a liquid,
than it does in air,
for that exact reason.
The particles in the
liquid are closer together.
Since they're closer
compacted, they collide more,
and the propagation of
the wave happens faster.
So different ways move at different speeds
and the medium through
which a wave travels
can also affect the speed of a wave.
All right, so let's try to
summarize all this information.
We have waves, a wave, a
disturbance that can propagate,
and it has a few key characteristics.
There's the period
or how long it takes
one cycle to complete,
there's the wavelength,
the distance between identical points
on two waves that are next to each other,
and the frequency,
which is how many waves
cycles complete in one second.
In this case, we have
two cycles in one second
for a frequency of 2hz.
Wave speed is found by multiplying
wavelength and frequency,
and that wave speed is
affected by the type of wave
and the medium through
which the wave travels.
Mechanical waves are ways
that travel through a medium,
so sound, a slinky or rope, ocean waves,
and electromagnetic waves
like light are special
because they can travel through a vacuum.
They don't have to have a
medium in order to propagate.
But all waves, no matter what type,
transfer energy, not matter.